you guys think hypergamy is a bad thing
I think it's a great thing you think
it's a great thing why
um our parking me has wait actually I'm
sorry I'm gonna say you guys didn't know
the definition of hypergamy earlier I'm
gonna say it and I'm Gonna Let You Go
Okay the definition of hypergamy is the
action of marrying or forming a sexual
relationship with a person of a superior
sociological or educational background
so that go ahead
um because you
women have to be strategic because you
mess up that you mess up you really mess
up your dating options right so and then
a woman's hypergly has the ability to
inspire her man to become greater and so
for that reason I think hypergamy is
absolutely fantastic what about women
that make a lot of money and they feel
like they need to date up do you think
it's still okay there what do we mean by
data just in terms of money money-wise
yeah
I don't know I I'm not sure something
like what if you make what's the
significant amount amount of money let's
say six figures I mean like one of the
stats they use is like women with a doc
like doctoral degree or the most single
so yeah and so and so the way that I
look at that is if you if you earn a
salary of twenty to fifty thousand
dollars but you're like five hundred
thousand dollars in debt well that
you're not doing No One's Gonna do
anything right yeah so to me if if we
just judge this by money then that's one
thing be with a man though that's
confident and secure with themselves
that it can provide a lifestyle that you
guys can be happy with and go with that
because at the end of the day money that
stuff can change okay you think
hypergamy is a bad thing no it's
actually great that women want the best
DNA they can get and the best result for
their life but it's just on steroids too
much in the United States okay yeah
y'all are very unrealistic I love that
you put in the United States
there's a difference there's a
difference it's been to Brazil he knows
it
ah
hypergamy is it a bad thing no I think
it's a good thing and I actually like
what uh Sergio said too that it does
inspire man because with men know and
understand that it's competition out
here it just makes them a little bit
more competitive
what about you guys yeah I think it's a
great thing and once you've had that
once
um I think it's hard to go back had what
once had hypergamy had somebody that was
um financially stable who was Superior
than you I think I don't know if it
creates a block but in my mind it's hard
to go to date down
do you do you think so are you saying if
you had like an ex-boyfriend that made
say 75 000 it would be hard to go down
from that something like that I think
yeah once you have experienced a type of
Lifestyle it is it is difficult do you
think it's the same thing with like a
few let's say you had one boyfriend that
made 75 000 and then you had another
boyfriend that maybe he was six two like
would you say it's it's each trait like
the best in them is hard to go down from
yeah I think most of relationships that
I've been in I always try to take the
best part of that person and I'm gonna
not gonna lie I do try to look for that
in another person I try not to compare
relationships or men
um but there are certain qualities that
if I've had it I'm like okay I'm not
gonna I'm sorry I'm not gonna date to a
five five foot person when I've
experienced a six foot like I just no
maybe you're being unrealistic but
that's my well yeah my experience
that was an extreme example okay there's
not that many fast food I'll give a
couple inches
same thing would you say when you date
up you don't want to date down anymore
at all would you guys say that makes it
like understandable why a guy doesn't
want a girl that's like been with a lot
of guys
because because like there's more that
we would compare it to yes yeah
yeah
it's interesting like most girls when I
ask them this they're like no yeah
I don't think anybody wants
anyone yeah yeah
well if they're just using her as a hoe
yeah
what about you um yeah hypergamy is a
the thing I think though with social
media you know dating apps and stuff we
don't know when to satisfy like what we
have so we're always looking for the
next best thing
um and to to your point yeah it's
definitely hard to date someone who is
tall you know you could wear your heels
and then
yeah you know
especially that you can't but then it's
also like you have to as you said you
know pick out the best things in the
relationship and look for it what I had
a question if I had
um since we're talking about have part
of me do you think that in a
relationship
and or somebody that's married do you
think the woman ever shuts off
as far as looking for a
hypergamous man like if she finds one at
that time like there's a man just I got
him cool but does she still keep looking
low key behind the scenes I think that's
why it's important for men to always
all weather because then if I say we got
together and you know you made like I
don't know 50k a year and then in two
years you're making like 75k that's
still technically hypergamy because I'm
I'm with the same guy but you know
different status okay so basically no
no I'm looking at the same guy
but like different like improvements but
if you stayed at that 50 000 then it's
gonna be a problem eventually no yes I
think I will be honest yeah I think it's
no good problem yeah
I mean you got it yeah
yeah I know it's a little bit but let's
just say it's 75 right and you're
interested when you find someone that's
introduced into that lifestyle at the 75
okay you guys are living if he stays if
he stays at 75k and the life just stays
the same I think that you're gonna go
looking around especially if you're not
married but I think even women that I
married still looking around and they
low-key comparing
looking at their husbands like you know
why is this person this person like he's
doing this so it is important for men to
always level up as you said because this
man it's a competition out here like I
think that's just how men and women are
wired a certain way and I think women
are going to always be looking
yeah do you think men are hypergamous
too
I'm somebody asking this question
earlier I'll let y'all go first the
homosexuals are but regular masculine
men absolutely not no no I'm not talking
about for money so like like I would say
money to women's looks to them Let's see
we can't mention those two I can invest
money and grow it I can't invest looks
right so so typically men are not
hypergamous we want we want a decent
woman and if you happen to be Stellar
especially after you get 30. when you
get 20s and stuff you want the best
looks you want what you want as you get
older you get more established I would
rather have a seven six seven wife who
is loyal who's faithful who who's
inspiring being to have a dime and I
can't rely on her so I think it changes
as you get older it's not a stranger
I've heard that from guys because when I
ask guys like the questions of like what
how attractive a girl has to be and that
sort of thing their answers seem to
differ in their 20s than their 30s
would you what do you think I'm
hypergamous yeah I mean you had the
nines
no I mean a little bit because she got
away with more because she was hotter no
that's because I was younger oh okay
yeah okay no I know better now you said
you wouldn't let a six get away with it
huh you said you wouldn't let a six get
away with what you got away with
yeah never at any point in my life
I'm not pregnant though because I went
to Brazil
so you you think
um because you can get all what you what
he just described in that country okay
where are you gonna bring one back no
I'm going there oh you're gonna move
there he's not coming in a few days oh
shut up you're at you're literally
leaving the country yeah oh my God I did
not know that that's crazy
with the United States you're real upset
with the United States yeah what's
what's tell me the difference between
Brazilian and American women oh I did a
video on this
I can't believe wow you said in two days
they have Clarity okay they usually more
fit okay they don't argue that does not
mean they don't have an opinion
like I could see that I saw it just
because you don't have to being
submissive does not mean being a slave
or uh she doesn't have a say-so but we
don't argue about everything American
women typically not all of them but
typically they got to be careful with my
words so I I I'm with you typically
argue a lot
I think everything is just the opposite
everything is the opposite it's a needle
in the haystack you were born in the U.S
right yes do you ever think that a
Brazilian woman is just trying to submit
to get this citizenship here we go
I lived in Miami and there's a lot of
you know South American women that do do
that and well they're in America but but
they don't want to come here not the
majority of them
I did an interview yesterday and they
all say they would rather live in Brazil
okay or somewhere else not the United
States yeah maybe just they're just
culturally different
it is definitely a cultural difference
they're beautiful there too yeah like
all the Brazil all the Brazilian nannies
I had were literally
that's not how Burger me yeah
no because I mean a lot of girls will
say it's like extreme but I kind of get
it but like it just just because I think
in the U.S like men value Purity youth
but in the US the average age of first
marriage Roman is like 28 like how pure
and Youthful are you at 28.
you agree disagree I don't really think
about marriage that much right now so I
don't know I didn't even just go to ask
me the question again uh
uh no I was just saying like I underst
like a lot of girls think it's extreme
to like move for that oh for women but I
I kind of guess it's a shaming day but
they always
it's not extreme
she had mentioned something you said
it's culturally they're different yeah
do you find that it's like so it's
American culture that you have American
culture is dumb yes
my personality is not for the United
States now okay
talk
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible